this is all the first time for you guys
to go to VidCon yeah yes yeah and what's
your experience
before
what
a lot of people Thank RTI seen them
throw the cards away and trashes which
kind of made it disappointed and a bit
mad gets pretty rude yeah like they
would like take our cars here in the
trash but like we do help like people
who are you it's kind of weird but like
this is like the little people like like
I you only have like you know 45
subscribers like a hundred like that
though kind of like just like blow it
off a little bit then if you have like
like just so we handed out something
like the big people and they're like
yeah definitely goes to traffic they're
the ones who actually your subscriber I
was kind of weird yeah like the big
people want help you go help you get
through what they went through just
kinda like experience they don't want to
go to that kind of thing you think
they're more collaborative and maybe
what yeah
yeah probably you're not as afraid
yeah they may be like you know just not
afraid but it's like I've seen that
happen like we were here yesterday for
VidCon and he exact actually gave
someone a ticket and they a lot who saw
them throw it in the trash right as they
walked away are you trying to sure
laughing a little bit cuz we can't
really care to be honest because you
know you just got to let that let those
things go so how was it you're like
really mad just like yeah it's just kind
of rude you like do it right in front of
us like at least now do it when you get
home I don't know just going up to the
after they feel a while excuse me blah
blah blah publix make it worse and more
irritating
oh yes so what would you tell other
supposing you
to the context here
yeah just let him go in kind of like if
we're we may come here next year and if
people had ice courage or something then
we'll definitely go and subscribe
because we did it like this this year so
you kind of want to help them out and
like we don't want to blow them off or
something we've honor because if it's
helped like if you want to grow your
business you got to promote it kind of
so what we thought you know just get
cards and hand them out to people at
VidCon so yeah it's like
yes
what do you see the future into
having you two around
I doubt we're gonna be su jazz vs T like
any you know big company like shane
johnson or anyone like that like smoosh
baby about his big ass I'm the beginning
women like 200,000 subscribers that's
kind of our goal like a hundred thousand
that would he just be insane she get a
hundred thousands of drivers are you
crazy just to get it now yeah just to
get a thousand hydrate rings yeah yeah
every every one subscriber as as one
huge step closer to our goal yeah it's
kind of like if you've ever heard like
that penny expression like one penny
always count it's like one subscriber
always counts so yeah so what's the
biggest lesson I'm starting this channel
from whether to not
while you not take them personally or
just the value
mine has never never give up features
and helps you with patients
I think we're done ok
I never give up never surrender got from
the line from this movie I watched it
super fun galaxy quest okay let's calm
so
measured almost of websites thank you
very much thank you thank you for having
us Jim all right thank you very much
you